I will you this
is the wired autocomplete inter
view
Joe Goldberg hey you has this person
seen the show it's hello
you
[Music]
what does Penn Badgley think of you I
like you I mean I don't know you but I
think I like you oh
oh it's the show of course I like it I'm
indebted to the creators I love the
experience for what it's been which is
very intense very very intense but I
like you
and I love you did Pan Badgley Know Dan
was Gossip Girl no not certainly not in
the beginning nobody knew the writers
even they've been clear about this they
had to decide who it was in the last
season you know for for like a finale
and I think he made the most sense I
found out I think just right before we
started shooting the episode I really
didn't know was coming down the pike but
in the end I'm I'm happy to to wear the
the crown
the moniker why is Penn Badgley Twitter
cardi B is that a sentence the world may
never know first of all cardi was the
first one to uh to switch her icon and
then I was like I think I have to switch
my icon now cardi B has just made me her
icon I think I need to make her mine I
texted a few friends I was like hey what
picture of her should I use I'm like
what I had I had to do some ketchup I
did use a little quick Google search and
then I saw there was this whole thing
behind a wig and I was like that's the
one and it worked how old was Penn
Badgley
in Easy A older than High School
criminally old to be playing a high
schooler
22 at least but I was doing I was
lifting more weights then you know
brought children 23 year old Penn Valley
hmm playing a teenager I do love Lobster
Todd who doesn't get out of here go
Google yourself huh okay
what band is Penn Badgley
in it's called mother spelled with an X
tragically hipster X because of legal
reasons by the way it's m-o-t-h-x-r we
just we wanted the e but there are
several other mothers and one of them
served as a cease and desist letter in
person actually we were outside of a
show he just strolled up to me after
we'd play and I was talking to some
people he said are you him Badgley and I
was like yeah because a lot of people
outside of the shows would ask me that
and then he goes oh here he pulls out a
letter hands me the seasoned assist and
I was like
oh we're gonna have to change our name
what part of Baltimore is Penn Badgley
from okay so I was born in Baltimore
Johns Hopkins I was in the NICU for a
while so I might have been in the
hospital for a few weeks my parents at
the time lived in Annapolis and then I
was in Richmond Virginia and then I just
I kept moving as a kid so so I really
don't know Baltimore people give me a
lot of credit for for being from
Baltimore I'm not like super from there
a lot of my family is they know it will
I don't
What I Like About You Penn Badgley you
might be thinking like what do I like
about you starring Penn Badgley no
that's not what that's saying that is a
show starring Amanda Bynes she had a
sitcom called what I like about you and
I guest starred in an episode
which was a cross promotion at the time
for the show that I was starring in on
the same network called do-over
which you've never heard of and never
seen what is Penn Badgley doing now this
[Music]
now we're doing Joe Goldberg not a real
not a real man Joe Goldberg hey you has
this person seen the show it's hello
hello you hey you that's nice oh he
might say hey you I think he says hey
you like hey you in a bathtub I think he
says it who does Joe Goldberg love
nobody let's be careful now
nobody I mean I always knew that love
was gonna die I did not think she was
going to kill him I knew that the show
had too long left to go Joe Goldberg
doesn't even love himself this is the
thing some people might say like you
know men are trash this self-centered
narcissistic thing like narcissists
don't love themselves they can't love
themselves and therefore they can't love
anybody that's my understanding of like
the emotional and mental reality of love
and self-love why is Joe Goldberg
likable well because I play him
probably not very well meaning if he was
a real serial killer maybe he wouldn't
be that likable it's my fault I'll go
ahead and take it I'll take it I'll take
the fall I'll take the fall it's my
fault and the writers Joe
from you memes yeah that's one of the
best parts of the show let's be honest
that's like our our b-roll are the memes
which you are responsible for so thank
you
Joe Goldberg where does Joe Goldberg get
his money yeah where does he get his
money same place did like Arnold
Schwarzenegger got all his bullets and
would those movies he was in the movies
he got him from Hollywood so technically
he got it from Love's family in season
three in season two I mean let's be real
making one of those cages of which he's
made like several now that would cost
like thirty five thousand dollars at
least I mean he's not paying anybody for
the manual labor he's doing it himself
which also is
remarkable it's a good question keep
Googling how did Joe Goldberg get to
Paris with his money
personality type is Joe from you I feel
like I just heard this recently I feel
like I just heard uh it was in it infj
introverted something it's like an it's
it's an introverted something feeler
he's not that he's a fiction of your
imagination and he's a murderer what
does Joe Goldberg's kill count somebody
just told me that entering into season
four it's ten that may be accurate if
you would have asked me I would have
said something like 13. does Joe from
you get caught watch the show he kind of
does he gets caught repeatedly and he
gets away he's a Wily little it's a live
little Goldberg the question is will he
get caught well that's a secret I'll
never tell
is he gonna say it is he gonna say it
he's gonna say I'm not gonna say bye
Pam Badgley favorite books so it used to
be Kurt Vonnegut was my favorite author
I really loved Galapagos which is not
like the one that Kurt Vonnegut fans
name I've read two books of fiction in
the last 10 or 11 years swing Time by
zadie Smith and parable of the sower
favorite book I'll stick with Galapagos
Kurt Vonnegut
it's been magically's son and you my
real son oh no next question does Penn
Badgley like playing Joe playing Joe has
been very enriching I do like it I do
like it I like it the way you like going
to the gym when you know you might throw
up you ever done CrossFit I haven't but
you know I know that it can be intense
it's a little bit like that at least pen
badgely
nice it's not really for me to answer is
it leave that up to you
bye
who does Penn Badgley
look like myself thank you very much
I've heard John Mayer I've heard
countless other white guys on television
around my age who've been on CW shows
and other things like that Dylan O'Brien
right shout out to Dylan O'Brien I'm not
sure that we do look alike but I hear
that
did Penn Badgley drop out of Middle
School
yep I technically tested out of high
school early stopped going to middle
school skipped high school started
taking college courses so I could work
adult hours while I was working in in
television and film which all children
should do
and drop out of middle school I dropped
out of uh childhood is Penn Badgley
vegan no I might seem it it's uh
sometimes it's a compliment sometimes
it's offensive but no I I was vegan I
have done it before but I'm I'm not
vegan Penn Badgley first Tick Tock was a
hit what rock are you living under next
Penn badge lead Dancing Yeah I mean in
my first love singing and dancing it's a
search term
you know sometimes I wonder sometimes I
wonder how we got here who is Ben
Badgley married to Domino Kirk Domino
Kirk Badgley Domino Susie Kirk Franklin
we've been married for pushing on six
years Happy anniversary baby we have two
kids we have two dogs we have an
apartment in New York City I mean you
know living the life
there was a lot of questions there was
more questions than I thought it would
be so I'm good I'm good if you're good I
want you to be good
but I'm good